almost all medications for  antidepressants  and antipsychotics and and  benzodiazepines etc they're studied in  trials that are  primarily sort of six to eight weeks and  maybe sometimes 12 weeks and then the  problem  is that people don't get just treated  short-term they get treated long-term  and there are no long-term trials and we  actually don't know what the safety  of these drugs is long-term and that's  the huge issue and so if they only were  prescribed  four for six weeks and then it was  stopped probably much less  problems would occur but when when the  drugs are taken chronically  um your your brain becomes tolerant to  them  and your brain actually probably changes  and then when you when the drug is taken  away then  people are suffering uh in many cases  very severe  withdrawal effects for long periods of  time